well another way to see people's real
characters whether they tell the truth
about the powerful or whether they suck
up to the powerful
today over an msnbc on their morning
show
everybody nodded in bovine agreement
while
a world health organization official
gushed about the fascist government of
china watch this
right now there's very very few
countries that have actually been able
to reverse
this uh this epidemic and bring their
cases down to very low level and in fact
the only country that's done that is
china
it was the passion the diligence the
sense of responsibility the seriousness
of the average chinese and i want to use
that term very
carefully because they weren't average
they're extraordinary people but they
were driven by a sense of collective
responsibility
dave rubin hosts the reuben report on
youtube he joins us tonight he may not
be aware
dave rubin that these are extraordinary
people driven by a sense of collective
responsibility they're your moral
superiors they're doing the right thing
unlike america
how do you assess that claim about china
well collective is the key word there
they are a collectivist society we are
an individualist society but
specifically here
uh you know authoritarians love
authoritarianism meaning they love
central planning they love the idea that
the state can control everything that's
actually the reverse
of the american ethos now neither system
is
absolutely perfect but i personally
wouldn't want to trade in
my rights and my liberty and my free
speech and all of those things
to have a system of government that
could always tell me what to do
freedom is a little bit messy and we
have to fight that and negotiate that
with the people that would take our
freedoms away all the time
so what's particularly interesting here
though is that
you know what they're saying basically
is give all of your freedoms to the
state and then the state can somehow do
everything right
except what they forget is the back end
of that and the back end of that
is you you cow people into silence you
give away your freedoms
and and you end up living in a place
that most of us wouldn't want to live
which is why americans don't
leave because we got it pretty good
they're praising they're praising a
government that harvests the organs from
murdered political prisoners should that
make us nervous
well of course it should make us nervous
but the idea is
the same people who want to import
authoritarian ideas here
are the same people that love those
ideas elsewhere
so they never talk about the bad things
right they're not going to talk about
the bad things
about communism on msnbc because they
kind of like it right
so they slowly they tell you the good
things oh in times of crisis they've
been able to organize in a certain way
now that's also
if you're going to really believe the
numbers coming out of china
and everything else so it's hard to
figure out what's true right now
and i again freedom is the key thing
what we're all having to do right now is
decide
how much freedom do we want to give away
in the midst of a crisis and that's an
important debate to have it's one you've
been having quite well on this show
actually
we're trying there's so much going on
dave reuben great to see you tonight
thank you
thanks tucker if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell